when the Russian attack began chaos and
killing descended on Ukraine many
expected the country to fall and its
leader to flee and yet there he was
listen I am here he said we will defend
our state the world hardly knew Vladimir
zelenski
a former comedian known for a TV role as
The Accidental president of Ukraine as
the real leader he resisted efforts by
then U.S president Trump to dig up dirt
to hurt Joe Biden but few most notably
Vladimir Putin expected he could
withstand the Russian Onslaught
yet zelenski has been Resolute compared
with Winston Churchill in World War II
he has buoyed the spirits of the
Ukrainian people
and risked his life to be with soldiers
near the front lines glory to Ukraine he
tells them
there is a heavy toll but we've seen the
Ukrainian army fight back with Valor
with bravery and president zielinski as
the head of that government as the head
of that Army is is the brave face and
Communicator to the world about what's
happening in Ukraine zielinski has kept
the world's attention on Ukraine kept
the West committed in its support the
choice for person of the year was the
most clear-cut in memory said Time
Magazine recognizing not only zelenski
but the spirit of Ukraine the strength
of its people after almost 10 months of
war the country is a shell of its former
existence this man looks at the car he
used to drive a woman is grateful just
to receive water yet their Spirit has
not faltered
Ukraine will win we will get through it
she says we will prevail
the soldiers and the people are one in
their determination to fight on for a
country that has long resisted Russian
subjugation the more the Russians attack
the Ukrainian civilian population the
less afraid they are zielinski embodies
that unity and the spirit of a nation
that will not give in to tyranny the
role of a lifetime for a comedian turned
president Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto